let me show you how to create your
database and run migrations using App
Engine flux and rails I've written a nap
and I'm using the my sequel to gem to
connect to my database I've created a
second generation cloud sequel instance
called rails instance and I set up the
username and password that my rails app
will use I've also downloaded the cloud
sequel proxy and I have it running in
the background to connect my rails app
to my cloud sequel instance I need to
get the connection name from g-cloud i
use g-cloud sequel instances described
and then my instance name and since i
just need the connection name I'll pipe
that through grap i take the connection
name and i can put it in my database
tamil
I also add the user name and password
while I'm in here since the proxy is
running I can set my rails apps to
production and I can use my regular
rails commands to run the database
create and database migrations
now I'm ready to deploy my app to app
engine I hope this was helpful